mes chers
collègues dans la ligée de la précédente
audition celle du au Conseil de la
famille de l'enfance et de l'âge nous
poursuivons nos travaux sur les familles
monoparentales avec l'audition de
Nicolas Grivel directeur général de la
Caisse nationale d'allocation familiale
il est accompagné de Barbora braviova
conseillère en politique sociale et
familiale à la CAF bienvenue et merci
pour votre présence ce matin j'ai à mes
côtés les deux rapporteurs de notre
mission flash colombe Brusselles et
Béatrice goselin laacnaf est chargée de
la définition de la stratégie de la
branche famille à l'échelle nationale
elle pilote et anime le réseau des 101
CAF de France réparti sur l'ensemble du
territoire qui assure le versement de
prestations sociales et familiales dont
bénéficie 33 millions de personnes soit
près de la moitié de la population
monsieur le directeur général vous nous
donnerez des éléments sur les
caractéristiques des familles
monoparentales parmi le public des CAF
en particulier le montant moyen de
prestation qu'elles reçoivent les aides
auxquels elles sont éligibles et les
difficultés qu'elles rencontre en tant
qu'à loocataire les prestations sont
essentielles pour bon nombre de ces
familles au niveau de vie nettement
inférieur à celui des autres familles 41
% des enfants en famille monoparentale
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté contre
16 % des enfants dont les parents sont
en couple des évolutions de ces
prestations sont-elles envisagées en
particulier quelle appréciation
portez-vous sur une éventuelle
déconjugalisation de laallocation de
soutien familial
laasf quelles seraient ses conséquences
sur les familles monoparentales et sur
les finances publiques avez-vous des
données sur l'ampleur du non recours au
droit par par les familles
monoparentales dont l'audition
précédente nous a dit qu'elle semblait
que ce non recours semblait important en
parallèle des articles de presse
notamment une enquête du journal Le
Monde publiée en décembre 2023 ont mis
en lumière une
surreprésentation des familles
monoparentales dans les contrôles
effectués par les CAF à même niveau de
revenu et ont par conséquent dénoncé le
caractère discriminatoire de
l'algorithme utilisé comment
justifiez-vous cette surreprésentation
des familles monoparentales au sein de
ces
contrôles nous nous intéressons
également au sujet des pensions
alimentaires quel bilan pouvez-vous
dresser de la mise en place de l'agence
de recouvrement et d'intermédiation des
pensions alimentaires l'ARIPA et de
l'action des cafs dans la matière y
a-t-il des problématiques spécifiques
rencontrées par les cafs selon les
département un prélèvement à la source
de la pension alimentaire ne pourrait-il
pas être plus efficace en se référant au
modèle
québécois enfin vous pourrez nous faire
part des initiatives mises en place par
les CAF au niveau national ou local pour
mieux accompagner les familles
monoparentales et de vos éventuelles
préconisations à la matière certains de
nos interlocuteurs ont évoqué la
création d'une carte famille
monoparentale sur le modèle de la carte
famille nombreuse cette mise en place
vous semble-t-elle opportune vous avez
également reçu en amont de cette
audition un questionnaire pour lequel
nous attendons des réponses écrites au
plus tard le 1er février s'il vous plaît
Monsieur le Directeur général je vous
laisse sans plus tarder la
parole merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrice ravi d'être avec vous ce matin
de poursuivre votre cycle d'audition que
vous avez qui vous a permis notamment de
d'entendre les auteurs d'un ouvrage
qu'on peut considérer comme de référence
en tout cas je je l'espère sur les
familles monoparentales que que la knaf
a diligenté dans sa fonction étude
recherche et qui je crois fait l'état
des savoirs c'est le nom de la
collection et le nom de du dispositif
sur le sujet et donc il vous a d'ors et
déjà je crois apporté à la fois par
l'audition et puis par la lecture ou par
le fait que vous ayez pu parcourir ce
cet ouvrage je pense beaucoup
d'informations uties et précieuses et
c'est pour ça que nous avions choisi ce
thème il y a quelques années maintenant
parce que c'est le genre de de démarche
qui prennent du temps en terme de
consolidation de l'ensemble des savoirs
des recherches sur un sur un sujet nous
avions et vous avez ressenti ce
besoin eu la volonté de d'apporter un
certain nombre d'éclairage sur
cette catégorie groupe des familles
monoparentales don qui est pas à la fois
un sujet nouveau mais qui est un sujet
dont on voit
bien la montée en puissance statistique
que vous avez bien en tête bah qui
occupe désormais qui est devenu un objet
de politique publique en tant que tel et
un objet social bien entendu bien avant
d'être un objet de politique publique et
donc voilà on avait le même ressenti que
vous au moment où vous avez lancé cette
cette mission sur ce sujet on souhaitait
pouvoir y contribuer par cette cette
approche un peu scientifique et
objectivé encore une fois c'est pas la
production de laacnaf c'est une
production diligentée par la CNAF avec
voilà vraiment des des des sachant
j'allais dire les experts sur ce sujet
qui ont pu documenter cet aspect là donc
je
je suis d'autant plus ravi de le faire
qu'on se s'inscrit dans ce dans ce
contexte et que on a une attention très
forte sur les familles M parental on l'
l'pporté ces dernières années je vais
revenir avec toutes vos questions sur le
développement d'un certain nombre
d'outils d'allocation de
dispositifs qui de notre point de vue
était délibérément tourné vers les
enjeux de famille monoparental et en
particulier les femmes puisque vous
connaissez les statistiques sur la part
très très prépondérante des femmes qui
représente plus de 80 % des situations
de famille monoparental
concerné on a aujourd'hui on estime
qu'on compte plus de 2 millions famill
monoparental dans nos allocatairesin de
de manière générale sur nos 13 millions
d'allocataires et donc on est sur une
proportion évidemment importante on a
enfin clairement un phénomène de montée
en puissance que vous avez déjà perçu
documenté si on regarde si on compare
par rapport à l'année 2000 on a
finalement à peu près le même nombre de
couples avec enfants à charge dans nos
statistique globalement en tant que tel
tandis que le nombre de parents isolés a
augmenté en moyenne de 2 % par an hein
donc une augmentation continue et forte
sur sur cette période euh typiquement de
de de ces situations fille monoparental
on a un certain nombre de dispositifs
spécifiques qui nous permettent
d'appréhender le phénomène hein et du
coup de mesurer le le phénomène parce
que c'est c'est toujours le sujet hein
c'est que pour mieux mesurer
statistiquement enfin vous mesurez
souvent mieux statistiquement quand vous
avez derrière de la gestion financière
administrative spécifique qui renvoie
une catégorie de population donc on
n'est pas on n'est pas sur des
évaluations en l'occurrence on est dans
la mesure de dispositif spécifique avec
des dispositifs de majoration des
montants de prestation hein comme vous
le savez il y a des majorations sur le
RSA 615000 bénéficiaires sur la prime
d'activité 881000 bénéficiaires et puis
des règles de prise en charge des
ressources plus favorables notamment sur
les calculs des allocations familiales
avec des PLA prises en compte de plafond
plus adapter à ces situations on a
également un certain nombre d'aide
financière individuelle c'estàdire plus
ponctuel plus à la main des CAF
localement et à la main des travers
sociaux qui accompagnent et je
reviendrai sur le parcours séparation
qu'on a qu'on a mis en place dans ce
dans ce dispositif et puis une
prestation exclusivement dédiée aux
situations de séparation et d'isolement
qui est laallocation de soutien familial
sur laquelle vous
m'interrogiez qui est une allocation
importante 800000 familles qui
bénéficient et donc dans la situation
d'isolement avec une actualité assez
assez forte puisque c'est une allocation
qui a été revalorisée en novembre 2022
comme vous le savez de 50 % qui a été
porté à 184 € qui est environ le montant
moyen de de prestation de de pension
alimentaire pour avir un enfant et donc
la règle étant de effectivement de de
permettre par la surélévation de cette
allocation
de remplir la fonction défaillante entre
guillemets d'une pension alimentaire qui
ne peut pas être versée absence de
situation permettant ce ce versement ou
en l'attente dans un verersement
notamment dans cette dans sa dimension
recouvrable en fait puisque on va dans
certains cas palier l'absence momentanée
d'une pension alimentaire et ensuite
récupérer le montant versé auprès du
débiteur sur la sur la pension
alimentaire et donc c'est une prestation
qui qui est significative
importante
utile pour cou ouvrir ces situation
d'isolement et de famille monoparentale
alors vous nous interrogez sur le débat
de la déconjugalisation de cette
allocation de de soutien
familial qui voilà se situe dans le dans
le débat public une je crois une
proposition de loi franceç souis qui a
été déposée mais pas débattu je crois à
l'Assemblée sur sur ce sujet et puis ça
s'inscrit peut-être dans un mouvement de
réflexion un peu plus global puisque
nous avons procédé en octobre 3 la
déconjugalisation de la location adulte
handicapé dans un autre contexte
évidemment sur un autre dispositif mais
on voit bien la tension qui peut exister
sur le modèle entre guillemets familial
de versement des des prestations avec ce
qui send derrière en terme de solidarité
familiale parce que la logique qui est
derrière c'est la logique que quand on
est une famille Ben se soutient on on
accompagne les frais de de la famille de
de de manière générale alors on se situe
sur un débat pardon voulez réagir je
disais quelle est la définition de la
famille en l'occurrence c'est c'est
c'est un beau débat qui pourrait nous
prendre un petit peu plus de temps que
le temps octroyer pour pour cette
audition mais en
l'occurrence le sujet c'est précisément
quand il y a pas de famille c'estàd
quand il y a
isolement qu'on m une prestation
spécifique
comment quand même oui tout à fait tout
à fait tout à fait bien
sûr je Jes pas ça du tout non mais y a
pas de problème je me sens pas taquiné
enfin alors
gentiment mais mais précisément parce
qu'il y a famille et qu'il y a pas
solidarité familiale de quelqu'un qui
peut voilà partager les frais qui s'y
attache ben il y a cette solidarité
nationale qui qui intervient voilà après
le débat il est un tout petit peu enfin
il est très intéressant il peut être
perçu comme un peu paradoxal dans le
sens où la logique est de se
dire parM les famille monoparentales ce
qui est intéressant je trouve c'est que
le le concept de famille monoparentale
il s'est imposé il est présent pour
autant il revit des situations très
différentes et il recouvre des
situations très très hétérogènes et on
peut avoir des situations de famille
monoparental qui sont pas exposé à la
pauvreté qui sont pas exposer à la
disparition complète d'un père puisque
on peut avoir un père qui est par
ailleurs présent dans l'éducation des
enfants qui verse la pension alimentaire
dans des conditions tout à fait tout à
fait normal euh voilà et on a des
situations à l'inverse très fortes de
pauvreté connaiss la prévalence forte de
de de ces sujets et de disparition
complète du père pour des raisons varié
et donc ça renvoie des situations
différentes et donc parmi les familles
monoparentales la situation des parents
complètement isolés et en l'occurrence
souvent des femmes complètement isolées
sans doute celle qui est la plus forte
en terme de d'exposition à la à la
pauvreté et donc puisque cette situation
est la plus forte on a des systèmes de
prestation plus favorables et plus
dédiés et notamment la question de
soutien familial et donc avec la
condition d'isolement qui renvoie
justement à cette logique de puisque
vous êtes isolé on a une prestation
spécifique et donc
après on réinterroge le sujet vu de
l'autre côté en disant bah oui mais si
cette personne se remet en
couple vous enlevez la loocation de
soutien familial mais dans la condition
initiale c'est l'isolement donc c'est un
peu totologique voyez le le le sujet
donc ça peut ouvrir beaucoup de débats
allez-y alors c'était le cas quand la
location s'appelait à location parents
isolé or là maintenant c'est LOCATION de
soutien familial et donc plus
spécifiquement dirigé vers l'enfant on
parle plus justement d'un loocation liée
aux parents isolés c'est pas la même
prestation la loocation de parents
isolés et correspond à majoré dont je
parlais précisément la location de
soutien familial c'est une autre
prestation plus limitée dans son
historique historiquement bah si elle a
toujours été mais c'est intéressant de
s'inroger sur ce ce sujet à l'origine
c'est une loocation d'orphelina c'était
le père est décédé on vous verse une
prestation pour vous aider au soutien
familial de la famille donc elle a
changé de nature par définition mais
elle a toujours été dans cette condition
d'isolement a toujours été posé en tant
que TER voilà et donc derrière ça
renvoie au sujet de quels sont les
situation qu'on accompagne et où on met
l'argent de la solidarité nationale
parce que ça c'est l'argent de la
solidarité nationale et donc évidemment
s'il y a pas de s'il y a pas de limite
dans l'argent on peut faire des choix
s'il y a forcément des limites et donc
les choix peuvent être guidés par par ça
le moi je je je trouve c'est un débat
intéressant donc je je je pose le débat
après c'est un débat politique évident
le de ce point de vue le la
revalorisation de 50 % c'est
l'allocation de soutien familial pour
les personnes qui ont remplissent les
condition donc il sont isolés et sans
doute une mesure qui cible davantage les
populations les plus précaires et les
plus pauvres euh dans ce dispositif que
la mesure de déconjugalisation en
elle-même qui du coup va peut traiter de
manière indistincte des situation
sociale très différente selon la façon
dont on
est positionné dans l'échelle des
ressources c'est une une prestation sans
conditions ressources et selon la
situation dont on a par ailleurs une vie
conjugale avec quelqu'un qui peut avoir
des ressources he donc c'est je trouve
que le débat il est et déjà bien sûr
voilà mais
c'est bien sûr mais enfin encore une
fois tout c'est tout ça existe mais la
notion d'isolement renvoie à des surcûts
individuels par rapport au logement par
rapport à plein de plein de paramètres
mais bien sûr que tout ça est je dis pas
qu'il faut pas aborder la question je
dis juste voilà dans le la façon dont on
réfléchit il faut à la fois comprendre
et connaître l'origine de la de la
prestation et puis voir la diversité des
situations
qu'c se faisant dans le dans le
dispositif mais encore une fois c'est un
débat plus politique technique et voilà
qui est dans notre dans notre rôle nous
on a applique la la législation si la
législation évolue ben on appliquera la
législation qu' aura évolué il y a pas
de il y a pas de débat là-dessus mais
c'est je trouve très intéressant en
terme de philosophie de système de
prestation d'où on vient où on va et
comment on fait évoluer les choses mais
c'est c'est cette logique là qui
aujourd'hui
prévant voilà vous signalez juste qu'on
avait Mame rosignol je pense connait
bien le sujet expérimenter dans le ce
qui était avant l'ARIPA avant
l'intermédiation des pensions
alimentaires l'expériment une
expérimentation 2014 sur le maintien de
la SF en cas de reprise de la vie
commune avec un conjoint différent de
celui du père des
enfantsin en l'occurrence et donc c une
expéentation de 2014 on avait sur un
temps relativement limité mais un
relativement faible volume de situation
1200 personnes qu'on avait été amené à
accompagner dans ce dans ce cadre de
situation sur un total de 800000
familles globalement hein donc le le
sujet peut exister dans sa dans sa
caractérisation à l'occasion de cette
expérimentation il avait pas non plus
été le signe d'une volumétrie très
importante mais il faut aussi limiter
cette interprétation au fait que c'est
une expation de courte durée dans une
période voilà qui peut renvoyer aussi au
sujet du du recours que vous avez par
ailleurs questionné j j'y viens j'y
viens désormais c'est effectivement un
sujet global hein pour nous le N recour
comme vous le savez on a des prestations
importante qui donne lieu à des taux de
non recours aussi très significatifs he
près de 30 % sur le RSA sur la prime
d'activité donc tout confondu hein pas
pas ciblé sur les familles
monoparentales et donc la la question du
droit au recours et de la façon dont on
accède au droit est très forte de
manière générale dans du dispositif et
on y est très on est très mobilisé sur
ces sujets avec une réforme importante
en cours sur ce qu'on appelle la
solidarité à la source qui vise à
connaître les revenus des allocataires
de manière générale et à leur faciliter
la vie dans le parcours déclaratif qui
est très exigeant et très complexe et à
stabiliser du coup les versements de
droit puisque vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
quand on fait des déclarations
trimestrielles sur le RSA la prime
d'activité on la de monre ces
déclarations à nos allocataires et dans
60 % des cas ils commettent des erreurs
dans leur déclaration ce qui est pas
tout à fait illogique vu la complexité
du système et que dans dans dans nombre
de ces carart on va être obligé expost
de corriger le montant des PR station
versé et dans 2 ti3 des cas de demander
de l'argent en des indus pardon aux
allocataire concerné ce qui est
évidemment la situation la plus
difficile pour des personnes qui sont
fragiles qui ont reçu une aide et qui
doivent en rembourser une partie souvent
étalé sur un certain nombre de mois mais
c'est pas facile donc ça contribue au
non recours en est conscient et certains
et sans doute de manière très
significative dans les familles
monoparentales qui sont les plus
fragiles les plus exposés donc le fait
de faire cette réforme de la solidarité
à la source pour nous doit être un
élément de simplification de
stabilisation des droits et du coup
d'amélioration du niveau de vie des
personnes concernées de manière générale
compris pour les familles monoparentales
la loocation de soutien familial est une
des prestations sur lesquels on a T de
recours c'est toujours difficile
d'estimer le recours à for sur une
prestation de volumétrie plus plus
faible mais on sait qu'il y a un taux de
recours important et on se donne
progressivement les moyens d'identifier
ce n recours et d'avoir des campagnes
d'accès au droit vis-à-vis des publics
concernés euh qui nous ont permis par
exemple sur une campagne menée fin 2021
d'aller chercher 3000 personnes et
d'ouvrir des droits à la SF à 3000
personnes femmes très très très très
majoritairement euh touché par la
méconnaissance en fait de cette
prestation alors même que nous nous
avions les informations et la perception
que ces personnes pouvent avoir droit à
cette
prestation alors ce qui est toujours
difficile dans les campagnes d'accès au
droit
c'est que le on cible un d'allocataire
par l'utilisation de nos données donc de
croisement de données on pourrait parler
d'algorithme en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence d'algorithme très ciblé on
va revenenir sur le sujet des
algorithmes de manière subséquente mais
cet algorithme est trèsèairement ciblé
sur les familles parentales et famille
isolé pour leur faire bénéficier de
laallocation de soutien familial et donc
on a en l'occurrence ciblé 63000
dossiers pour à la fin ouvrir 3000
droits donc ça veut dire que parfois il
y a des ciblages sur lesquels on n
pasment toutes les informations et donc
tous les droits ne se pouvaient pas en
réalité être ouvert mais on a un tô de
déperdition très important de personnes
qui répondent pas quand on les Appell de
personnes qui ne font pas la démarche
même quand on leur dit qu' peuvent faire
la démarche vous savez que quand on fait
des SMS ou qu'on passe un coup de fil en
disant c'est la CAF une bonne partie des
gens pensent que c'est une blague donc
enfin ou que
c'est du piratage une tentative de
piratage et cetera ce qui existe par
ailleurs donc c'est bien que les gens
soient un peu méfiants mais c'est vrai
que ils sont pas habitués à ce qu'on les
appelle pour leur ouvrir des droits hein
donc une partie de ces gens sont en
difficulté sociale et ont du mal à faire
valoir leur droits même contre leurque
il y a des droits et donc c'est des
sujets qui sont voilà toujours délicats
pour autant 3000 personnes bah c'est
trop chour 3000 personnes de plus qui
sont rentré dans le dispositif et donc
ça vaut le coup de faire ce genre de
campagne et et les poursuivre en ayant
progressivement le maximum
d'informations pour que nos propres
ciblages soient le plus les plus
pertinents possible pour pour intervenir
donc voilà pour sur laallocation de
soutien familial à la fois un dispositif
très important pour nous revorisé très
significativement ce qui c'est vu dans
les chiffres en terme de mobilisation du
dispositif et très utile pour les
familles qui sont
concernées alors vous nous interrogez
sur les algorithmes je en parl à
uninstant alors j'imagine que
l'algorithme qui fait de l'acès au droit
ne vous choque pas par principe euh
l'algorithme qui déclenche des contrôles
peut générer plus de de questionnement
on a effectivement eu plusieurs articles
de presse ces derniers mois on a une
première série il y a un an et une série
plus plus récente qui bon fonctionne un
peu toujours sur le même mécanisme
euh on est toujours un peu surpris de ce
type de débat le dans le sens où le
l'algorithme en l'occurrence c'est un
exercice ENF un outil d'une grande
grande simplicité enfin c'est pas
l'intelligence artificielle qui va faire
big Brower pour aller chercher des gens
qu'on aaurait pas trouvé et cetera c'est
un algorithme qui nous renvoie le
refleet statistique de nos prestations
hein qui nous renvoie la prévalence
statistique des différentes situations
et qui les lie au phénomène que
j'aiévoqué précédemment qui est le
phénomène du risque d'indu c'estàdire du
risque de trop perçu euh parce que
risque
d'erreur majoritairement d'erreur il y a
des indus qui sont frauduleux ça existe
mais ils sont très très minoritaires
dans le flot no de nos indus
et donc nous notre sujet c'est de
d'appliquer la loi d'appliquer les
textes de verser ce qu'on appelle le
juste droit ni plus ni moins que ce qui
est le juste
droit et donc de s'assurer du respect
des droits et du fait qu'on a versé ce
qui était devait être versé et donc les
situations qui génèent le plus d'indu
sont pour nous les situations les plus
préoccupantes parce Queen fait générer
des indus ça veut dire embêter les gens
après pour aller récupérer des indus et
ce qui est encore une fois le pire du
service public qu'on qu'on peut rendre
de dire je vous ai versé 600 € par mois
puis un an et demi après excusez-moi
vous vous êtes trompé dans votre
déclaration je vous aurais dû versé que
450 € merci de me rembourser 750 € fois
18 mois vous voyez bien l'impact que ça
peut avoir sur les allocataires qui sont
qui sont concernés et donc dans le
système actuel puisqu'on est pas encore
dans la solidarité à la source c'est
vraiment l'objectif de de notre système
d'algorithme d'aller détecter les
situations qui génère le plus
d'un et donc dans dans ce st algorithme
il nous R renvoie la réalité statistique
de notre fichier donc qui nous renvoie
évidemment plutôt des populations en
précarité en difficulté parce qu'on
verse assez peu de prestations ciblé sur
les publics les plus riches dans notre
dans notre société et il renvoie les
bénéficiires des prestations les plus
complexes qui sont génératrices de plus
d'erreurs et donc de plus d'indu et il
nous renvoie les situations familiales
qui sont génératrices elles-même dans
ces prestations complexes du plus de
difficultés du plus d'erreurs et donc du
plus d'indu qui sont les situations est
plus instable en réalité parce
que on lit dans certains articles vous
chassez les pauvres et cetera et cetera
en fait la situation la plus difficile
c'est pas la celle des gens les plus
pauvres qui ont zéro revenus en
permanence cette situation elle génère
très peu de situations de d'indu la
situation est plus difficile c'est les
gens qui alternent les situations
professionnelles qui ont des statuts
différents qui ont plusieurs employeurs
et qui sont on peut tout à fait le
comprendre complètement perdu quand il
s'agit de déclarer tous les trimestres
leurs ressources en plus selon des
règles qui suppose pas seulement de
reproduire ce qui est en bas à droite de
la fiche de paye mais de faire des
soustractions des additions selon tel ou
tel paramètrre selon qu'ils ont eu des
frais réels sel qu' des frais de repas
des frais de formation des choses comme
ça et donc c'est ça qui génère de la de
la difficulté et donc de
l'incompréhension et donc des erreurs et
donc des intu et donc c'est cette
situation ces situations là qui
ressortent statistiquement très
simplement de nos algorithmes et qui
suppose qu'on aille regarder de plus
près de manière très minoritaire
on fait 4 millions de contrôles chaque
année il y a que 6 % qui sont outillés
par cet algorithme sachant que
l'algorithme ne fait qu'un outillage de
public qui potentiellement présente un
risque statistique important mais
derrière c'est un humain qui regarde la
situation de ces personnes contrôle ces
situations il y a rien à dire on dit
rien il y a une situation on doit de
l'argent à la locataire qui s'est trompé
en sa défaveur 31 % des cas c'est pas
rien donc dans 31% des cas on donne de
l'argent en plus à laallocataire parce
qu'il s'est trompé en sa défaveur et
dans les de/ers des cas il s'est trompé
en sa faveur donc ind duu et donc
procédure de de de remboursement et donc
c'est c'est c'est c'est ça ça que sert
cet algorithme à bien cibler à bien
identifier les situations les plus
risquées y compris pour faire de la part
de le contrôleur un travail de pédagogie
vis-à-vis de ces public parce que les
gens qui se trompent un trimestre de
trimestres trois trimestres sur leur
déclaration il y a un risque très fort
qui se trompe
sans cesse sur leur déclaration pour les
mêmes raisons et donc qu'on puisse leur
expliquer le plus tôt possible ce qu'ils
doivent déclarer comment ils doivent
déclarer pour ne pas régénérer de de
l'essus donc dans ce contexte là c'est
pas très étonnant nous on cible pas les
familles monoparentales pas du tout mais
quand on regarde la prévalence
statistique de nos publics et des
erreurs c'est pas étonnant qu'on tombe
sur des catégories très représentées
dans No dispositifs et pour toutes les
raisons que je vous ai indiqué tout à
l'heure on a des dispositifs plus
favorables pour les familles
monoparentales et donc des sptif à la
fois plus plus favorable financièrement
et donc si le risque d'erreur existe B
il est plus important parce que il a un
impact financier plus plus important
et puisque la condition d'isolement est
une condition sur plusieurs de ces
majorations et plusieurs de ses
prestations vous savez que le sujet de
la conjugalité est un sujet important de
la situation familiale dans
l'appréciation de nos sujet et donc le
contrôle de cette situation là fait
partie des sujets importants qu'on doit
vérifier parce que que si la personne
est en couple alors qu'elle nous a dit
qu'elle était isolée ben il y a un
problème par rapport à la délivrance de
la prestation et donc par nature
j'allais dire la situation de famille
parentale exige un certain nombre de
situations et notamment cette situation
conjugale et de non conjugalité qui fait
que ces public
ressortent spécifiquement mais c'est
c'est en fait c'est la réalité qui guide
l'algorithme et pas contraire voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est la
réalité statistique des situations qui
nous permet ensuite de détecter des
situations identiques qui présentent des
risques et donc on va vérifier et s'il y
a pas de sujet il y a pas de sujet voilà
un peu le la la lecture qu'on peut faire
de ce sujet qui pour nous de ce point de
vue-là peut susciter des débats certes
mais qui ne renvoit pas à des
problématiques discriminatoires des
problématiques de ciblage de fliquage
des familles monoparentales en tant que
tel pour la raison qu'elles sont
qu'elles sont
monoparent alors vous nous interrogez
sur un belle réforme qui a étéci
quelques quelques années par étape
successive et qui a conduit à la mise en
place de l'agence de recouvrement et
d'intermédiation des pensions
alimentaires la Ripa et surtout la la
mise en place de ce qu'on appelle
l'intermédiation financière des pensions
alimentaires avec l'idée que c'est un
phénomène de masse un/3 de pensions
alimentaire partiellement ou
irrégulièrement payé donc générant des
des impayés très significatifs et
contribuant à l'aggravation des
phénomènes déjà documentés de
pauvreté des personnes con conerné par
ces séparations et euh et les femmes en
particulier et donc de ce phénomène de
de société très très large et apparu
l'idée que la puissance publique enfin
on est en fait dans un système de
relation privée hein vous allez devant
le juge il indorce le juge dit monsieur
vous devez donner 30 d'euros à à Madame
mais que sans le système de régulation
publique on arrivait à ce système de
d'un payer très très massif et donc la
mise en place de cette intermédiation
financière pouvait permettre dans une
logique de prévention alors il y a deux
dimensions hein il y a une dimension de
il y a un problème il faut le résoudre
et donc il faut aider au recouvrement
des impayés de pension alimentairirees
mais progressivement la conviction qui
s'est imposée c'est que il fallait être
plus en prévention en anticipation et
que en mettant en service public les CAF
en l'occurrence entre un débiteur et un
créancier sur ces situations on allait
progressivement dissuader ou réduire le
risque euh d'un payé euh et se faisant
progressivement diminuer ce taux de de
30 % et que pour nous vous percevez bien
intervenir dans une situation normale
banalisée de versement régulier sans
problème dans dans une
famille après séparation c'est quand
même beaucoup plus simple que d'aller
commencer l'intervention au moment où il
y a 12 mois 18 mois d'un payer à aller
récupérer sur une personne qui aura pas
forcément la capacité de payer tous ses
impayés et de rattraper des situations
très problématiques qui par d'illeurs en
venime la relation dans un couple peut
être facteur de violence ça existe peut
être facteur de dégradation de la
situation d'éducation des enfants et de
relation entre les deux parents et les
enfants et donc de dire le but c'est de
banaliser neutraliser le plus possible
ce sujet en mettant un service public
entre les deux parents séparés et que
les parents séparés se parlent plutôt de
sujet d'éducation de coparentalité de
façon de les problématiques des des
enfants plutôt que de problématiques
financières si elles sont neutralisées
et gérées par ailleurs donc on a eu
comme vous le savez plusieurs étapes
successives on est maintenant arrivé à
l'étape ultime disons de mise en place
systématique par principe de
l'intermédiation financière vous savez
qu'on a inversé le principe au début il
fallait opter pour l'intermédiation
financière il suffisait qu'un des deux
parents demande à bénéficier de
l'intermédiation financière pour la
mettre en place ce qu'on voyait dans la
pratique c'était quand même souvent
parce qu'il y avait un problème que la
tion a été faite et donc souvent trop
tard et donc souvent parce qu'il y avait
déjà plusieurs mois d' payer de pension
alimentairire et donc progressivement on
a mis en place des systèmes où par
principe vous êtes dans l'intermédiation
c'est seulement si les deux parents s'y
opposent que vous ne rentrez pas dans
l'intermédiation financière et donc
depuis le 1er janvier 2023 ça couvre
toutes les situations de séparation il y
a plusieurs étape d'abord les situation
devant le juge puis toutes les
situations de divorce par consentement
mutuel y compris en passant par d'autres
dispositifs dont les don les avocats
donc aujourd'hui on a sur l'ensemble des
demandes qu'on a reçu près de 200000
situations qui ont donné lieu à mise en
place soit d'intermédiation financière
plus de
150000 dossiers soit de mise en place de
dossierers avec la location de soutien
familial récupérable c'est-à-dire ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure la
capacité d'aller ensuite récupérer
laalcation de soutien familial vis-à-vis
du du débiteur et donc une montée en
charge très puissante de ce disposi
dans les derniers mois enfin 2023 et
début 2024 on est à un rythme en fait de
10000 demandes par mois supplémentaire
sans un payer et 5000 demandes par mois
de demande avec recouvrement de d'un
pays hein donc et ça continue ça monter
en charge donc on est sur une adaptation
très forte de ce dispositif et et une
satisfaction globale on a réalisé une
étude qui a été publiée il y a une
quinzaine de jours que auquel vous
pourrez vous reppporter vous a transmise
peut-être qui montre globalement une une
satisfaction de plus de 8 mè/ 10 dans le
dispositif la mise en place de ce de ce
dispositif avec des effets positifs
d'accompagnement matériel psychologique
et encore une fois de le neutralisation
enfin de faire vivre cette pension comme
un droit reconnu plutôt que comme une
bataille un peu permanente pour obtenir
les financements correspondants ce que
je trouve intéressant également et ce
qui est signalé par beaucoup beaucoup
d'équipe dans les CAF quand je me
déplace à leur rencontre sur ces sujets
de pension alimentaire c'est que
finalement le sujet de la mire était
perçu dès le départ puisque c'est la
philosophie du dispositif hein d'aider
les mes c'est quand même souvent les mes
à récupérer et à obtenir dans des temps
et en leur porension alimentaire le
sujet qui est apparu c'est le sujet des
paires c'est que du coup en en faisant
l'intermédation on discute avec les pè
on échange avec les paè que beaucoup
apprécient pas tous mais parfois se sent
un petit peu challenger entre guillemets
dans le dispositif mais beaucoup
apprécient en fait cet exercice de
neutralisation de sujet parce que c'est
conflictuel c'est tendu euh voilà et
puis dans certains cas c'est l'occasion
de détecter des situations là aussi
d'accès au droit des situations sociales
compliquées des sujets d'accompagnement
et donc on peut par l'accompagnement des
paires et l'accès au droit euh qu'on
peut ouvrir à certaines prestations
auquell il bénéficier peut-être pas
faciliter le versement de la pension euh
parce que de fait financièrement ça
redevient possible c'était compliqué
précédemment donc c'est quelque chose
aussi d'intéressant dans la façon dont
le dispositif se met en place de manière
assez assez forte encore une fois on n
pas encore le recul d'une année complète
enfin on a 2023 la première année
complète on va pouvoir l'analyser mais
il y a quand même une monté en charge un
peu continue ce qu'on voit c'est que le
dispositif fonctionne bien avec les
tribunaux tout le Monte judiciaire s'est
mis en place et ça pas été simple
forcément au début mais on est quelque
chose maintenant sur quelque chose qui
fonctionne de manière assez fluide il
est encore ass s début sur le rôle des
avocats dans les procédures qui passent
par les avocats où on sent queil y a des
questionnement parfois des réticences
sur la mise en place du dispositif de la
part d'avocat qui peuvent conseiller à
leur clients dire bah tout se passe bien
entre vous c'est c'est un cons mutuel
vous êtes d'accord sur la pension
alimentaire il y a pas de problème vous
avez pas besoin de passer par la CAF ce
qui est pas tout à fait la philosophie
de la réforme puisque les 30 % d' payé
si on savait les détectter au premier
jour du divorce ou de la séparation ça
serait très simple en réalité ça peut se
passer bien pendant 3 ans 5 ans 10 ans
et puis d'un coup des difficultés des
remises en couple des enfants nouveaux
dans des frateries et cetera et quelque
chose qui se passait très bien peut d'un
coup ne plus bien se passer et donc le
la philosophie de la réforme c'est bien
de la faire la prévention la plus
complète et de le mettre en place pour
tout le monde même quand ça se passe
bien bah si ça se passe bien ça se
passera bien aussi dans le système
d'éisation nous on reçoit l'argent on
Leever il y a pas de problème mais tout
est fluide euh et ça prévient peut-être
des difficultés qui seraient survenu 3
ans ou 5 ans après VO donc un point
d'attention encore sur sur ce sujet euh
évidemment voilà je regardais un peu le
le questionnement que vous avez sur sur
ce sujet aujourd'hui enfin le dispositif
tel qu'il est il nous paraî assez fluide
et assez adapté dans sa dans sa mise en
place il y a on a un point de vigilance
sur les délais de démarrage du
dispositif hein parce que on
a beaucoup d'informations à récupérer en
peu de temps pour brancher le circuit de
versement et parfois des
incompréhensions des bénéficiaires des
parents sur ce qu' doiv faire dans
l'intervalle selon ce délai euh parce
que on
a une obligation évidemment de verser la
pension tant qu'on n pas intervenu nous
he et du coup
parfois une compréhension puisque ça va
se passer comme ça et même si se passe
un mois ou deux ben en fait la pension
est pas activée au début ce qui fait que
finalement on commence avec un
appayé alors que la situation le le
justifia pas qu'il y avit pas forcément
de problème donc il y a un peu de
pédagogie à faire là-dessus peut-être
progressivement aussi un exercice un peu
de de revue et de toilettage de texte
qui ont été définis à l'origine dans des
situations problématiques tendu
contentieuses j'allais dire entre les
les conjoints et qui du coup sont
prévoient des procédures très normées
très établies d'aller tour d'accord de
transmission des documents et cetera et
cetera et qui peut-être dans un certain
cas sont un peu lourdes par rapport à
des situations qui sont très
consensuelles en réalité et qui du coup
prennent un peu de temps au démarrage et
créer cette situation initiale un tout
petit peu incertaine là-dessus
voilà donc ça fait partie des des sujets
un peu de vigilance je pense qu'on a pas
encore assez de recul pour aller dans
plus loin dans les types de réflexion
que vous évoquiez du type prélèvement à
la source ou pas qui pose un certain
nombre d' d'autres d'autres questions ce
qui est certain c'est que euh on est on
est quand même dans un dispositif qui
peut être très fluide tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui lorsque les choses se
mettent en place avec le le prélèvement
automatique avec tout ça qui fait que
beaucoup de situations qui se passent
très bien en réité hein donc euh on
n'est
pas on n pas encore enfin je pense qu'il
faut faire vivre le dispositif et
prendre peut-être deux ou TR années de
recul pour apprécier euh ce qui doit
être fait et peut être fait là là-dessus
le parmi les améliorations
qu'on sur lesquelles on réfléchit il y a
le lien avec le sujet précédent qui est
l'allocation de soutien familial et le
fait que on puisse rendre de manière
plus
systématique le fait que la l'entrée
dans le dispositif
haripa vaille quelque part demande
d'allocation de soutien familial en cas
de difficulté de versement là où
finalement il faudrait faire une demande
supplémentaire en cas de difficulté
aujourd'hui ce qui peut contribuer au N
recours qu'on qu'on développé tout à
l'heure donc ça fait partie des
questionnements qui sont les notes et
les réflexions qui sont les notes voilà
pour terminer vous nous demandiez le des
des informations sur la façon dont les
cafes sont mobilisé pour accompagner les
familles monoparentales comme je le
disais c'est vraiment un de nos public
très très très prioritaire peut-être
quelques mots sur le parcours séparation
qu'on a lancé en 2021 qui est un
parcours d'accompagnement un peu global
à la fois d'accès au droit et
d'accompagnement social par nos
travailleurs sociaux euh des personnes
qui qui concernent des parents concernés
quand il y a une séparation qui est un
parcours vraiment d'aller vert on parle
souvent de ce terme qui est un parcours
qui fait que systématiquement quand on a
connaissance d'une séparation on propose
un accompagnement et on propose aux
personnes de rentrer dans ce parcours
séparation qui peut être un parcours
très court pour donner quelques conseils
quelques informations et cetera et puis
les parents ressentent pas le besoin
supplémentaire ou un parcours plus dense
si on sent qu'il y a des choses assez
lourd à à à mettre en place et donc
d'information sur les droits et devoirs
prévenir les situations les plus
fragiles les plus délicates euh et
parfois identifier des situations de
violence he ça peut arriver que c'est à
cette occasion du parcours séparation
qu'on identifie ces situations de de
violence conjugale et mettre en place
les éléments de coparentalité qui vont
continuer à s'exercer parce que c'est un
sujet vraiment très très important c'est
c'est un des sujets là aussi de
peut-être du paradoxe du du terme
monoparental c'est que le beaucoup de
situations de famille monoparental il y
a il y a deux parents même s'ils sont
séparés et que la qualité de l'éducation
le lien qui
perdure avec les enfants et la façon
dont ça se passe est crucial y compris
pour les enfants et le développement de
l'enfant et et l'harmonie de ces sujets
et donc tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on met
en place de manière la plus apaisée
possible au début doit faciliter ça si
on sent qu'il y a des difficultés on a
un certain nombre de gamme de
d'interventions par la médiation
familiale par de l'aide à domicile qui
peut intervenir sur ces sujets pour
initier les choses et par le financement
des espaces de rencontre qui peut aussi
des lieux où on organise ces formes de
rencontres dans les situations un peu
plus difficiles euh pour que le lien ne
se rompe pas
totalement et donc là on a quand même
une 400000 familles par ans qui qui
rentrent dans ce parcours séparation et
donc c'est c'est une intervention tout à
fait euh importante et quand les gens
leur quand on leur propose
dans un cas sur deux les parents
viennent vers nous souvent les femmes
mais pour rentrer dans ce parcours
séparation on a y compris avec nos
collègues de la MSA un certain nombre
d'initiativ sur les situations de répi
familial qui peuvent être des sujets
importants pour le pour les parents qui
sont qui sont concernés et les
monoparents en l'occurrence aussi dans
les situations de d'enfants handicapés
hein c'est un des sujets qui peuvent
être évidemment très très lourds et donc
là aussi c'est on voit syématique qui
est qui monte et qui s'accompagne
souvent au niveau local par les CAF on a
l'enjeu très fort de l'accès au ce qu'on
appelle désormais le service public de
la petite enfance et plus globalement
sur les sujets de d'accès à nos services
aux familles qui sont évidemment ouverts
pour toutes les familles pas seulement
pour les familles monoparentales mais
pour lesquelles les sujets d'accès pour
les familles monoparentales sont
particulièrement
posé l'étude l'état des savoirs montit
bien que les familles parentales avaient
plus de mal à accéder à ces services
très fréquemment ça renvoie pour la
petite enfance à des sujets de
d'attribution de place et au critères
des collectivités locales souvent pour
l'entrer dans ces dispositifs ça renvoie
à des sujets financiers aussi pour
l'accès aux différents modes d'accueil
des jeunes enfants vous savez que
les les tous les services aux famill
sont pas provoque pas le bêm reste à
charge pour les familles et que pour les
familles les plus précaires les modes
d'accueil ne sont pas tous ouverts dans
les mêmes conditions notamment le mode
d'accueil individuel donc la réforme du
complément mode de garde qui est en
cours va permettre d'égaliser de lisser
c'est rest à charge pour l'ensemble des
familles donc ça bénéficiera aux
familles monoparentales et puis de
développer les formules de d'oraire
atypique les formules de lien avec les
parents dans les lieux d'accueil enfants
parents les formules de crèche av
voocation d'insertion professionnelle
permettant à une femme qui souhaite
reprendre un parcours professionnel de
d'avoir des heures d'accueil des jeunes
enfants qui lui soi offert dans ce dans
cette tranche là et puis ce sujet
s'arrête pas à 3 ans et donc on a le
sujet de la conciliation aussi avec les
accueils sans hébergement les accueils
de loisirs sur lesquels on va
expérimenter un
barê national qui pourrait permettre de
laisser la place à tarification
spécifique pour les familles
monoparentales voilà ce que je pouvais
vous dire globalement sur en réponse à
vos
questions je vais laisser la parole à
nos rapporteurs juste il y a une
question il me semble pas que vous y aez
répondu sur sur la carte sur la carte
famille monoparentale oui alors je sais
pas ce que ça appliquerait exactement
alors en fait c'est à l'exemple de la de
la carte de la famille nombreuse puisque
finalement on est famille nombreus quand
on a trois enfants c'est-à-dire que en
gros quand on est famille monoparentale
à partir d'un enfant et demi on serait
famille nombreuse
et donc ça peut se
justifier donc
voilà après ça renvoie quels sont les
services
comment j'ai c'est le un enfant et demi
est pas facile à évidemment appréhender
le ça envoie à la question de quels
seraiit les services offerts par cette
cette carte c'est-à-dire que vous savez
que la carte famille nombreuse elle a
pas non plus
une renvoie à certainemble de service
mais pas non plus
un volume illimité de servicees euh et
donc voilà ça renvoie aux problématiques
notamment SNCF qui sont très marqué
puisqueil y a eu plein de débats sur ce
sujet de l'utilisation de la carte
famille nombreuse et de la tarification
et des applications financières que ça
pouvait générer plus tous les services
publics locaux en fait en réalité que ce
soit l'accès à la culture que ça soit un
certain nombre de de sujets euh voilà et
après ça renvoie à la difficulté de
gérer ce genre de dispositif qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'une famille monoparentale
jusqu'à et à partir de quand on est fa
parental comment on gère quelque chose
qui est voilà potentiellement aussi
variable dans le
temps sur ce genre de dispositif qui un
peu un peu ciblé quoi voilà mais on n
pas expertisé plus que plus avant
puisquon n
pas visibilité sur les contours exacts
que prendrait cette ce
dispositif oui merci beaucoup monsieur
pour cet exposé moi j'avais deux
questions alors vous avez parlé un petit
peu du du de la lisibilité du manque de
réactivité un petit peu du service aripa
qui fait que le temps que les données
soient enregistrées et cetera euh ça le
délai de démarrage peut-être un peu un
peu long et parfois aussi vous parliez
de familles qui sont les plus exposé qui
sont les familles où les parcours sont
plus chaotiques ou plus incertain et
donc parfois des situations de de
professionnelles changent et on met à la
fois le le la personne qui qui verse la
prestation famili qui verse le
complément familial en difficulté où on
met la maman en difficulté parce qu'il
n'est pas versé est-ce que est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire quelle serait en
dehors du prélèvement à la source des
solutions vous en avez un peu parlé vous
disiez que vous étiez en en recherche de
de d'amélioration mais est-ce que vous
avez imaginé quelques procédures qui
pourraient faire évoluer rapidement
cette ce ce cette fluctation qui est
évidente dans ces familles un peu
fragiles et qui qui qui en souffre ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
étant de sénatrice d'une d'une d'un
département rural vous parliez donc de
de de surtout des répis familiaux qui
peuvent être apporté par la CAF et la
MSA est-ce que vous avez une idée un
petit peu du nombre de structures qui
peuvent envisager qui peuvent proposer
ça dans les départements combien est-ce
que avez-vous un nombre à peu près de de
structures qui peuvent proposer ces
répis familiaux qui sont indispensables
et nécessaires aux familles
monoparentales merci donc sur le le
premier aspect c'est c'est moins un
sujet de manque de réactivité même si le
la montée en charge très forte du
dispositif fait que c'est des flux très
conséquents je vous ai donné les
chiffres tout à l'heure et donc on a des
équipes qui se sont adapté évidemment en
volumétrie mais on est quand même un peu
sous tension de de ce fait là on va de
nous-même essayer de faire un certain
nombre de progrès dans l'outillage on a
c'est un service qui est venu de enfin
qui s'est créé pas nulle part mais enfin
de qui est monté en charge quand même
très très fortement ces dernières années
donc on va progressivement améliorer
l'outillage les systèmes d'information
la façon de travailler pour autant il y
a il y a des étapes de démarrage qui
sont en fait un peu incontournable de
mise en place d'un service hein et donc
de transmission des choses avec la
justice c'est quand même assez fluide
parce qu'on leur a fourni un portail qui
permette en fait qui évite au parents de
faire la démarche après avoir été la
justice c'est finalement la justice qui
fait l'entrée dans le dispositif donc si
on avait pas ça on serait dans des
délais beaucoup plus conséquents de de
mise en charge montter en charge et puis
après de simplement d'initialisation
j'allais dire administrative hein de de
de relations financières qui vont qui
vont se mettre en place et donc
d'aller-retour de de courrier que la
qu'on doit adresser aux deux parents de
mise en place d'un système aussi bête
qu'un prélèvement automatique d'un de
choses comme ça voy c'est des choses qui
dans un certain nombre de cas sont enfin
peuvent prendre un peu de temps selon la
réactivité bah on est dans un sujet d'un
ou de mois c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
on attend pas un an mais vous voyez que
selon les cas enfin si on ne répond pas
dans les délais on on fait une relance
ENF voyez ce genre de chos les parents
ils gèrent beaucoup de choses en même
temps notamment dans ces
périodes on peut parfois manquer un peu
de voilà de réactivité de leur côté
aussi dans dans dans dans dans ces
sujets donc simplement ce que je disais
c'est quelque chose qu'il faudrait
regarder un peu plus filement et
travailler c'est que le ce dispositif s
mis en place initialement dans des
procédures de conflictualité et donc y
compris
pour mettre en place un respect des
droits contradiction voilà il y avait
des il y a des des procédures que
peut-être on pourrait en partie
simplifier de ce fait là et en tout cas
il faudrait les regarder de manière d'il
un peu nouveau contenu de l'inversion
complète de la logique dans de principe
c'est-à-dire que maintenant la la je
vous ai dit he 10000 demande sans un
payé 5000 avec un payé et surtout le
flux nouveau il est en principe dans
problématique puisque il est il est au
démarrage donc il y a il y a toutes ces
étapes là après c'est des étapes pas pas
simples parce que c'est c'est des
publics qui sont qu'on connaît pas
forcément qui nous connaissent pas
forcément euh c'est des publics qui en
fait sont pas venus pour mettre en place
l'intermédiation financière ilst sont
venus pour divorcer et mettre en place
ses dispositifs euh ou séparer et donc
voilà c'est quelque chose qui vient à
côté donc il y a tout un travail de
pédagogie d'information qu'on a beaucoup
fait auprès des professionnel de justice
parce qu'en fait le contact il se fait
pas avec nous il se fait beaucoup avec
les professionnels de de justice donc il
y a il y a vraiment faire rentrer dans
les meurs dans la pratique ce ce
dispositif et encore une fois on n pas
sur quelque chose de enfin de lourdement
problématique on est dans l'ordre de
l'amélioration et un peu Contin continu
et c'est pour ça que je CITIS ce sujet
c'est que c'est plus la compréhension
par les parents de ce qui à faire en
attendant que ça se mette en place parce
que finalement s'il y a que un mois ou
deux c'est pas très lourd mais s ont
comment non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que par rapport à ce qui était le
dispositif avant de vous Versier des P
alimentaires pendant des années puis à
un moment donné il y av un problème vous
intervenez donc évidemment il faut que
le paiement se fasse dans cette période
là et simplement le ça veut dire que si
le dispositif est pas encore en place il
faut que le débiteur il verse M c'est
qu'un mois il faut qu'il verse un mois
de pension alimentaire et pas qu'il
considère que parce que il a il y a une
démarche qui est en cours de mise en
place de l'intermédiation il a rien à
faire parce qu'autrement on va on va
commencer par un problème quelque part
alors qu'il y a pas de problème he et
donc c'est ça qu'il faut que les choses
soient soi culturé et partagé et
comprise par tous
là-dessus pardon le RI oui c'est quelque
chose qui qui est plutôt local et voilà
qui s'organise dans des partenariats
locaux qui est pas forcément
complètement développé sur le territoire
et qui peut renvoyer des situations très
différentes parce que vous parlez pas de
la même chose si vousz parlez d'un
enfant de 0 à 3 ans ou si vous parlez
d'un enfant plus plus âgé le sujet peut
exister oui
ou c'est ce que je dis c'est ce que je
dis c'est que c'est des réalité très
différentes parce que voyez bien que
c'est pas la même structure qui va
prendre en charge votre enfant de 0 à 3
ans ou qui va prendre un adolescent donc
c'est des partenariats locaux et des
offres de services local qui doivent se
trava traver sur des la petite enfance
comment on
organise des sujets de prise en charge
partielle quand la la famille la femme
en l'occurrence et pas dans une logique
de mon enfant je l'inscris dans un
système de garde du lundi au vendredi né
en mooins on connaît les avantages de la
socialisation on connait les avantages
pour le développement de l'enfant puis
c'est quelque part une forme de répi
aussi donc comment on
initialise ces logiques de partage du
temps aussi de venu dans des lieux
d'accueil enfants parents parce que ça
permet aussi de prendre un premier
mouvement euh dans le dans le collectif
et puis de dire bah il y a des
situations et des solutions et on sait
gérer des solutions c'est pas toujours
facile et pour les gestionnaires de
crèche ça suppose un peu de de
d'ingénierie mais on sait gérer une
situation on peut prendre votre enfant
une demi-journée par semaine et euh et
quelque part le répi et peut être un
objectif euh incident mais euh ça sert à
ça aussi voyez ce que je veux dire et ou
alors c'est le réplique et l'objectif
mais ça sert aussi à la socialisation
l'enfant tout ça se complète dans le
dispositif si on parle d'enfants plus
âgés c'est d'autres dispositifs qu'il
faut mettre en place d'autres
accompagnements on voit bien toute la
dimension accueil de loisirs qu'on
développe et qu'on a qu'on accompagne et
puis après il y a situation un peu plus
lourde et un peu plus difficile je
parlais de la situation d'enfant
situation de handicap tout à l'heure mal
fait comprendre parce que bien sûr tout
ces structures de de d'aide à garde de
l'enfant et cetera plus âgés plus jeune
et mais je pense quand vous parlez de
structure de
je j'étais dans dans avec une
association là ce weekend et c'était en
fait une association donc qui est aidée
par la CAF ludaf et la MSA et dont le le
principe est de proposer aux familles
aux parents isolés un moment de de de
répide dans le weekend c'est-à-dire de
de de leur donner de prendre les enfants
par groupe avec des avec des éducateurs
et cetera pour est-ce que vous avez je
voulais savoir à peu près si vous aviez
quelque chose qui s'étend à travers le
dans les différents départements ou si
c'est relativement encore des très très
à la marge
c'est je sais pas si on peut dire à la
marge mais en tout cas c'est plutôt en
cours de développement et donc c'est pas
généralisé il y a pas il y a pas une
offre de service nationale homogène sur
ces sujets aussi fortes que sur les
crèches ou les accueils de loisir c'est
beaucoup dans les partenariats locaux
c'est beaucoup dans les initiatives qui
qui se font mais c'est quelque chose qui
nous tient à cœur et qu'on a plutôt
tendance à
développer excusez-moi Colom
procède merci merci beaucoup
euh alors je reviendrai pas sur sur la
question contrôle et algorithme je sais
que d'autres d'autres collègues le le
feront peut-être juste une réflexion et
une question pour poursivre le
questionnement de de Béatrice goselin la
réflexion il se trouve que la la
première audition qu'on a organisé et
qui a lancé les travaux de de cette
mission c'était les autrice de l'ouvrage
que vous avez pinoté qui est un
ouvrage produit piloté par par la CAF
passionnant et avec une phrase que
j'avais trouvé marquante de la part de
celle qui avait coordonné les travaux
elle l'a dit beaucoup mieux que je ne
vais le dire qui consistait à dire
est-ce que nous sommes dans un pays dans
lequel il n'y a pas de prestation
d'accompagnement et de soutien aux
familles monoparentales la réponse est
non est-ce que l'ensemble de ces
prestations contribue à éviter la
précarité la réponse est malheureusement
non et je trouvais un peu paradoxal
pardon je je vous livre du coup cette
cette réflexion en direct que ayant posé
ce sujet là qui est un sujet absolument
majeur parce que un sujet qui renvoie
aux politiques publiques à quoi servent
les politiques publiques en terme de
soutien aux familles monoparentales et
d'évitement de de la précarité je
trouvais paradoxal que dans un moment où
il y a un constat unanime sur le fait
que la précarité augmente pour les
familles
monoparentales le le le le le ciblage
des contrôles de de de la knaf consiste
Infiné à à faire en sorte que vous
arriviez à identifier que 71 % des
familles qui sont accompagnés par la
CNAF financièrement avec des aides qui
manifestement n'arrivent pas à éviter la
précarité pour ces familles soit des
trop perçu je ne vous fais nul grièf
personnelle de ce sujet-là vous vous
mais voilà il y a une forme de paradoxe
quand l'ensemble des des politiques
publiques qui sont mises en œuvre
n'arrivve pas à éviter la l'augmentation
de la précarité à ce que finalement les
trop perçus eux-mêmes soient des des
accélérateurs certainement de précarité
mais fin de fin de la de de de cette
réflexion je reviens sur sur haripa vous
avez pu voir que on a été plusieurs à à
réagir sur le fait que considérer que
pour une famille même un mois ou de mois
à l'échelle alors en effet d'une vie
tout ça n'est pas grand-chose mais enfin
dans un contexte de séparation même le
non verersement y compris involontaire
parce que les processus ne sont pas
compris il a un impact dans la vie des
familles et ça n'est pas rien euh moi ce
que je je j'ai entendu tout ce que vous
nous avez dit sur la montée en en
puissance progressive le fait que c'est
beaucoup de travail évidemment de de de
prise en main je ça a réduit de combien
euh le pourcentage de 30 % de pension
alimentaire non payée parce que
l'objectif au point de départ de de
cette mise en uvre c'était de faire en
sorte plus pensioniment qui so payé
c'est quoi l'impact très concrètement et
puis peut-être deè sousqu j'imagine que
vous l'avez évalué c'est comment est-ce
qu'on peut quantifier la mobilisation de
la CAF sur ce sujet c'est soit en en
équivalent temp plein soit en euros mais
voilà comment on évalue le
l'investissement de la knaf sur ce
sujetl
merci merci beaucoup sur le sujet qui
était en parenthèse donc jeouvre une
parenthèse répondre mais sans polémique
aucune je pense qu'il faut il y a deux
débats différents entre c'est quoi le
niveau de solidarité nationale qu'on
attribue à telle ou telle catégorie de
population selon quel
critère
et quelles sont les conséquences de
faire appliquer cette législation
nationale C ces choix nationaux parce
que en réalité
le notre comment notre disposit et notre
aspiration et c'est bien la logique de
la solidarité à la source c'est de mieux
en mieux et de plus en plus verser bien
du premier coup le bon montant de
prestation nous le moins on a besoin de
contrôler le moins on a besoin de
rectifier les situations et le moins on
a besoin d'aller chercher des indus chez
des personnes le bureau sportte il y a
vraiment aucun problème
làdessus pour autant j'ai déjà été
interrogé non pas dans cette salle mais
dans une autre fréquemment par vos
collègues sur le fait que la Cour des
comptes a pas certifié les comptes de la
branche Chille l'année dernière
euh sur un seul motif le volume des
erreurs déclaratives des allocataires et
notre incapacité évidemment à récupérer
l'intégralité des sommes et on parle de
plusieurs milliards d'euros hein on
n'est pas sur des petites choses et donc
notre sujet à nous et le sujet de la
cour qu'on peut vraiment partager c'est
juste l'application de ce qu'on appelle
le juste droit c'est-à-dire ce que vous
avez déterminé ce que les lois
déterminent en terme de combien est dû
aux gens ni plus ni moins he et donc on
peut pas considérer que parce que pour
une bonne mauvaise raison quelqu'un a
reçu trop
d'argent et qu'on récupère l'argent qui
était versé en trop on contribue à la
pauvreté des gens par le système de
solidarité c'est normal que les gens
ilsent à quoi ils ont V après si on
trouve que c'est pas assez sur coris
droit c'est un notre débat et on peut
dire bah il faut augmenter les droits
faut verser plus revalorisation de 50 %
de la SF et cetera et cetera mais c'est
deux C deux aspects différents et on
peut pas évidemment en tant que service
public chargé de l'application des
textes on peut pas dire bon a qu' de pas
appliquer les textes et verser plus aux
gens comme ça ils seront moins pauvr
vous voyez ce que je veux dire on est on
est évidemment chargé d'appliquer les
texte et d'appliquer de verser ce qui ce
qui est
du sur le sujet de de l'arip je merci de
permett d' revenir j'ai pas dit c'est
pas grave si pas un mot ou deux non j'ai
pas dit ça du tout je dis juste dans
l'initialisation d'une relation
financière qui va durer et qu' voocation
a duré des
années un mois ou deux c'est vraiment
l'initialisation voilà si on était
capable dans un système de gestion de le
mettre en place en 3 jours moi je je ne
demande que ça évidemment et c'est plus
simple pour les gens de fait aujourd'hui
les allers-retours nécessaires avec les
familles pour mettre en place le
dispositif génè et encore une fois c'est
l'application des texte sur sur la façon
dont on fonctionne génère ces délis
notre charge également hein donc c'est
aussi un sujet de préoccupation pour
bien gérer ça initialiser le mieux
possible les choses à la fois la charge
d'initialisation et la charge qui est
liée à la gestion des impayés des
situations difficiles parce qu'en fait
la lourdeur est beaucoup plus sur les
situations problématiques que sur les
situations pas problématiqu et donc Mo
on aura de problème je vais revenir sur
votre question après Mo on aura de
problème et si on arrive progressivement
à diminuer le taux et à diminuer
situation on vient nous chercher trop
tard bah plus on aura de moyen à mettre
sur l'initialisation si les textes
s'ajustent progressivement nous permett
d'aller plus vite ça sera d'autant plus
fluide voyz ce que je veux dire donc je
dis pas que c'est pas un problème dis
c'est pour ça queailles parler c'est que
je considère que c'est un problème
d'autant que ça génère de la
compréhension parfois on peut rater un
mois de versement alors que on part dans
une relation consensuelle et on crée un
problème dès le départ quelque part même
s'il est rapidement résolu en réalité
parce qu'on va rapidement dire à la
personne vous auriez dû verser
directement euh cet argent et que les
choses se mettent en place mais ça
pourrait être un peu plus fluide de ce
point de vue-là et donc c'est un de nos
objectifs d'y travailler à la fois dans
nos capacités d'accompagnement et le cas
échéant dans des évolutions de texte
pour fluidifier euh cette cette période
initiale sur l'impact sur le taux c'est
beaucoup trop tôt malheureusement pour
euh répondre à cette à cette question il
nous faudra beaucoup plus de recul et
d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas un tau je
pense qu'on mesure instantanément je
pense qu'il faut un certain nombre
d'enquête d'appréciation sur sur ce
sujet il faut que vous ayez en
considération également que il y a
peut-être un effet déformant à mettre en
avant la montée en charge très forte du
dispositif de notre côté par rapport à
ce qui'est la réalité du stock si vous
me permettez ce terme voilà c'est que on
est beaucoup sur le flux mais que la
masse principale des pensions
alimentaires versé ou non verersé dans
ce p aujourd'hui ce sont des gens qui
sétaient séparés avant 2022 2023 hein et
donc et comme je vous le disais souvent
les problèmes d' payer ils viennent pas
du tout de suite au début bah évidemment
on va récupérer encore beaucoup et le
10000 5000 que je vous mentionnais là il
est je trouve que il est quand même
encore il y a encore trop de situation à
payer par rapport à la proportion de ce
qu'on de ce qu'on a géré oui bien sûr et
et donc ça veut dire qu'on récupère
encore beaucoup de situations du stock
de gens où quelqu'un nous dit bah j'aien
à payer je souhaite rentrer dans le
dispositif pour à la fois pour récupérer
ce que j'ai pas récupéré et puis pour
mettre en place un flux plus fluide et
naturel à l'avenir donc c'est encore à
trop tôt malheureusement pour répondre à
votre question ce qu'on voit bien quand
même c'est que la normalisation la
banalisation du dispositif fait que on
est sur un et c'est c'est naturel he
vous allez me dire mais la proportion de
cas problématique qu'on aura à gérer
diminue enfin qu'on a gérer diminue
progressivement parce que plus on va ug
monter le flux entre guillemets banal
normal qui se passe bien plus plus on va
réduire les situations problématiques
mais on est encore un loin de la masse
de des situations de de pension
alimentaire prononcé avant le la mise en
place de l'intermédiation donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on mesurera
progressivement et encore une fois sur
30 % si on arrive à 28 27 25 et ceter en
fa c'est déjà du gagner ça sera pas
instantané d'arriver à 3 ou 4 % sur ce
taux mais c'est bien l'objectif dans le
de la de la mise en place du dispositif
et puis vous avez une dernière question
qui m'
ché l'évaluation des moyens temp homme
on est à plus de 1 TP désormais sur
cette activité donc c'est c'est
conséquent on a objectivement et il faut
le souligner c'est une mission qui était
pas prévu par notre précédente
convention d'objectif et gestion à son
démarrage qui s'est mise en place en
quelques années et sur lesquel on a eu
des moyens de monter en charge y compris
encore dans la nouvelle convention
d'objectif et de gestion qu'on a signé
en en juillet pour pour accompagner le
mouvement et la la montée en charge
voilà après on peut toujours avoir débat
de est-ce que c'est suffisant est-ce que
la continuation de la montée en charge
ferit que il faut voilà mais c'est
quandême pas rien enfin il faut je pense
qu'il faut le souligner c'est pas on n
pas dû on n pas bricolé entre guillemets
pour mettre en place le dispositif c'est
dispositifs importants ça nous fait des
équipes conséquentes des équipes qui
sont très mobilisées des équipes on
outil de mieux en mieux parce que encore
une fois on a commencé de manière très
très rapide et spontané sur sur ce
dispositif très différent de ceux qu'on
gère par ailleurs et donc c'est quand
même je pense enfin on peut se féliciter
de du fait qu'il y a eu des répondants
collectifs sur sur ce sujet et que ce
service se met en place un nouveau
service public c'est pas si souvent
qu'on crée un nouveau service public
quelque part autour de ces pensions
alimentaires et c'est quelque chose qui
d'ailleurs souvent les gens on
comprennent pas complètement la logique
parce qu'on est tellement habitué à nous
voir comme versant des aides là quand
tout se passe bien on verse pas d'ID
prend de l'argent privé et on le fait
transiter vers un acteur privé et donc
c'est c'est pas un dispositif de génér
de dépenses publi si ce'est notre notre
dimension de gestion il y a parfois le
débat de est-ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
de mettre des gens qui gèrent dans un
service public des pensions alimentaires
quand tout se passe bien on peut avoir
ce débat je trouve que il est ENF il
faut vraiment le remettre dans la
philosophie de la réforme qui dire on
prévient des difficultés qui viendront
peut-être plus tard et on rend les
sujets complètement habituels et donc
c'est pour ça que je pense que
l'universalité est très intéressante sur
ce dispositif même si effectivement elle
est pas mentalement comprise
initialement
quoi un autre collègue je crois souhaite
pas
oui merci Monsieur le Directeur Général
heureux de vous retrouver aussi dans
d'autres circonstances on s'était croisé
du temps où vous étiez directeur général
de Lan rue à saint-toin tout à fait dans
d'autres sur d'autres projets merci pour
votre présentation moi je voulais
revenir tout simplement vous l'avez
compris je suis sénateur de la scène
Saint-Denis aujourd'hui et revenir sur
cette question de l'algorithme
évidemment j'ai bien entendu
explications mais j'avais deux euh deux
points très particuliers à à à remettre
en en lumière d'abord parce que lorsque
cet article dans la presse est sorti il
y a quelques mois euh nous avions
compris en scène Saint-Denis que c'est
l'algorithme qui était qui était qui
était déployé avait une vraie approche
gestionnaire et moi c'est la question
des critères de règle une approche très
gestionnaire avec des critère de réglage
de cet algorithme qui nous interpellit
euh très fortement cette saintonis avec
un ciblage particulier sur les les
maires célibataires à faible revenu ou
les personnes en situation de handicap
évidemment ça avait soulevé oui très
clairement une vive préoccupation chez
nous auprès des associations des élus
président de notre département Stéphane
Troussel avait saisi le Défenseur des
droits pour examiner les conséquences de
l'application de ces critères et parce
qu' aussi de notre point de vue cela
pouvait engendrer une discrimination
territoriale pour les habitants de notre
territoire avec des contrôles
comparativement plus nombreux
qu'ailleurs voilà ma première question
puisque lorsqu'on se positionne et qu'on
s'interroge sur notre département oui
c'est un département où euh notre
connaissance 2 tiers des contrôles vont
cibler des allocateurs précaires mais
parce que c'est un département qui
présente un taux de preté deux fois
supérieur à la moyenne nationale 61 % de
la population totale état locataire de
la CAF et les familles monoparentales
évidemment majoritairement des mères
célibataires sont sur représenté euh il
nous a apparu aussi et je voulais vous
entendre là-dessus que potentiellement
un des critères de cet algorithme
c'était un critère géographique qui
prenait en compte le lieu de résidence
et ça soulève légitimement des
inquiétudes dans la mesure où la
possibilité que le simple fait de
résider en scène Saint-Denis ou dans un
quartier défavorisé aggraverait ce
risque de contrôle ce qui pourrait
apparaître pour nous comme une
discrimination enfin mon deuxème point
au-delà des préoccupations je comprends
que cette utilisation du Data Mining de
l'algorithme et cetera avait été
expérimenté en 2004 déployé au niveau
national en 2010 à la demande du
Président de la République de l'époque
Nicolas Sarkozi pour se concentrer sur
la recherche à postérieur d'erreur
plutôt que sur leur prévention j'ai été
en 2000 je travaillé à la CAF en emploi
saisonnier d'été en juin juillet 2020
euh 2000
pardon le temps passe le temps passe
mais vous pouvez revenir si vousz sur
les allocations logement donc j'ai pu
voir j'avais pu voir c'était une mission
de renfort à l'époque la cave de playl
déjà dans la tour playel à l'époque et
j'avais pu voir aussi à l'époque le rôle
non seulement de contrôle mais de
conseil que nous avions à à mettre en
œuvre auprès des prestataires pour leur
donner une compréhension non seulement
du fonctionnement euh de leur droit mais
de leur capacité aussi à exprimer à
demander euh à déposer des dossiers et à
faire des demandes sur leur droits et
vous l'avez dit je relève ça monsieur le
directeur général que le système est
très complexe on en convient et on ne
peut pas en vouloir à nos locataires de
faire des erreurs voilà ma question elle
était assez simple enfin mes deux
questions et est-ce qu'il y a une
volonté éventuelle du côté de la CAF de
recentrer au-delà de la dimension
trouver les erreurs à poostéorie
travailler recentrer auprès des équipes
euh de la Caisse nationale à ce euh ce
travail de prévention d'explication et
de présentation des droits euh que les
que les allocataires dont les
allocataires pourraient bénéficier merci
merci beaucoup al j'ai fait un
développement déjà assez long je crois
sur le sujet des algorithmes tout à
l'heure je je je redis deux trois
choses encore une fois euh vous avez
bien vu les choses je pense dans votre
période saisonnier même si euh la
situation a pas pas fondamentalement
s'est amélioré sur certains aspects mais
je pense que beaucoup de choses que vous
avez vu sur reste reste valide
aujourd'hui on a des prestations qui
sont majoritairement tournées vers les
publics fragiles et parmi nos
prestations les prestations les plus
complexes sont tournées vers les publics
les plus fragiles parce qu'on a par
ailleurs si vous voyez le système
d'allocation familiale qui est par
ailleurs plus
universel une prestation extrêmement
simple on connaitt le nombre d'enfants
on a un bar c'est fini et on a une
information automatique sur les
naissances très peu de choses à faire si
le système des prestations familiales
universelles était très compliqué il
supposait une intervention très complexe
sur la déclaration des revenus on aurait
et c'était notre prestation principale
ou unique pour ris comme ça B on aurait
une représentation par l'algorithme mais
par l'utilisation statistique de ces
élément très différent de la population
donc c'est ça n'est que le reflet enfin
vraiment faut pas faut pas avoir une
vision de cet algorithme très big Brower
ça n'est qu'un refleet statistique
point
final après on peut se dire bah oui mais
du coup ça cible des populations c'est
les populations qui bénéficient ces
prestations avec les situations les plus
propices à faire des erreurs et donc à
générer ses indus qui sont pour vous
l'avez rappelé tout tous les problèmes
qui s'y attachent voilà après plus
carériser les choses je je trouve que le
ce sujet mérite c'est l'intérêt de nos
échanges mérite la pédagogie mérite de
la visibilité de la transparence et donc
nous on souhaite rentrer dans ce débat
et qu'on avait avant les les articles de
presse
d'ailleurs décider de lancer un travail
pluridisciplinaire avec des experts
d'horizons différents d'analyse de nos
pratiques sur ce sujet des algorithme et
que on souhaite à partir de ce printemps
parce que c'est un travail qui a démarré
il y a un an partager assez largement
avec les acteurs associatif public pour
expliquer ce que c'est montrer ce que
c'est pas et débattre parce que je pense
que c'est utile avoir ce débat
typiquement les articles ou certains
propos militants et cetera d'origine de
tout
ça pas les gens qui réagissent par
rapport à ce qui dit mais ceux qui
disent des choses disent par exemple SIG
vous ciblez les bénéficiaires de Laah et
donc les
handicapés voilà si on regarde
précisément le sujet j'ai
fait le paramètre qui ressort comme en
présentant des risques d'erreur
importants c'est les deâ qui travaille
et qui du coup ont des combinatoires de
déclarations à faire et des instabilité
de situation personnelle qui sont plus
importantes et qui génèent des erreurs
donc c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
handicapés ou ils sont bénéficiaires de
l'âge que ça ressort c'est parce que on
est dans une situation d'instabilité de
variabilité des ressources et de
complexité infinie parce que si vous
connaissez la hache et vous
connaissez les situations de travail
pour les personnes qui sont âge
objectivement complexité infini et donc
c'est là qu'il y a des erreurs qui
viennent se nicher et c'est donc c'est
là qu'on va mettre le public qui est
déjà fragile qui travail on va le mettre
dans un situation de risque vis-à-vis de
notre système d'allocation parce qu'on
va lui verser des choses et et que on va
lui récupérer après en l'occurrence et
donc c'est ça qui est ciblé c'est pas
les personnes handicapées c'est pas la
hâge de manière générale c'est ce ce
type de
situation pourquoi le pourquoi le
système comme ça c'est que on a un
système social qui est très réactif
c'est ce qu'on nous demande et c'est
c'est normal on veut s'adapter à
l'évolution des gens et de la situation
des gens parce que ils peuvent tomber
dans la pauvreté d'un coup il faut qu'on
puisse brancher un système social
là-dessus pour qu'il soit très réactif
le système on
demande de connaître des des ressources
très fraîches très récentes au G
aujourd'hui on n' pas l'information sur
ces ressources jusqu'à maintenant on pas
d'information sur ces ressources donc on
demande aux gens de nous les déclarer et
ce faisant il se trompe massivement 60 %
je disais sur RSA après une activité et
donc on génère un système qui par nature
génère sa sa propre difficulté et ses
propres incompréhensions et donc d'où le
la réforme de la solidarité à la source
en disant si on a les informations sur
les revenu des gens ils ont moins de
travail de déclaration ils auront juste
à vérifier on va faire des déclarations
préemplies et de et ben ils auront pas
ce travail de vérification expos de
est-ce qu'ils nous ont bien déclaré les
choses et donc c'est vraiment la nature
du système qu'on veut changer et moi je
serais ravi qu'on ait plus besoin
d'algorithme pour aller vérifier des
situations qu'on aura à la source pour
le coup éviter en terme d' éviter en
terme de de situation voilà et donc la
logique territoriale elle est
malheureusement le reflet de ça aussi
c'est que si vous avez sur un territoire
je connais effectivement un petit peu
laass vous l'avez rappelé vous avez une
concentration de public pauvre de public
en difficulté de public qui ont des
situations instables ben vous avez une
démultiplication du risque d'erreur qui
qui s'y attache et donc une attention
particulière qu'on doit avoir là-dessus
donc voilà c'est pour ça je trouve que
notre échange permet d'apporter un
certain nombre d'explication et je vous
en remercie c'est pour ça qu'on souhaite
faire à notre échelle et modeste mais un
débat un peu ouvert sur ce sujet là où
cette ces outils ont été créés vous vous
le rappelez dans une logique pas non pas
de de non transparence mais dans une
logique tellement statistique en disant
on veut pas d'intervention enfin on veut
pas bidouiller ces critères en fait on
fait juste un miroir statistique et donc
finalement ces critères ils ont pas
beaucoup de c'est pas c'est pas un choix
délibéré de dire je vais mettre cet
indicateur c'est juste la réalité
statistique qui va nous faire les choses
et donc là où pour le coup personne ne
regardaer c ces variables
pour ne pas être tenté de dire ah ben on
va pas prendre celle-là on va mettre
celle-là je vais plutôt mettre non c'est
vraiment neutre si on avait pas ces
systèmes ben le contrôleur il contrôler
quand même parce qu'il faut contrôler
des situations et il y a une réalité et
il le feraient avec leur savoir-faire
leur expertise et ben ils iraient voir
pour bonne part les mêm publics ou
peut-être parfois sur une base un peu
plus discrétionnaire ce qui est pas
forcément beaucoup mieux ou adapté pour
aller voir des situations qui présentent
pas réellement de risque et qui qui sont
pas totalement nécessaires de regarder
donc c'est ça le la logique dans
laquelle on se on se situe et vraiment
sans volonté de cibler discriminer
attaquer telle ou telle catégorie public
ou telle ou telle
territoire y a-t-il d'autres
questions puis-je vous poser une toute
petite question hors hors cadre alors là
pour le coup c'est euh enfin hors cadre
ou pas d'ailleurs non sur laallocation
universelle d'urgence qui a été mise en
placeit euh nous dire comment ça se met
en place parce que c'est diff difficile
de vous avoir là et pas vous poser cette
question tout de même écoutez ça se
c'est donc une n d'urgence que vous
aviez voté il y a moins d'un anit elle a
été votée en février à l'initiative de
Valérie lettard qui était ici au
Sénat qui nous a demandé un peu de
réactivité aussi pour mettre en place ce
dispositif à comptter du 1er
décembre et qui est un dispositif que je
trouve très intéressant et dans déjà
utile parce que on a une sollicitation
des sollicitations fortes qui voilà qui
sont
voilà qui témoine du phénomène en
réalité et et du besoin on a
euh une appréciation déjà positive sur
la façon dont on a su se mobiliser les
ces onont su se mobiliser trèsactive à
des sollicitations fortes vous nous
avvez fixé des délaiis très court 3 à 5
jours pour verser cette aide c'est des
délaiis qu'on arrive à tenir dans la
majorité des cas parfois il y a un peu
d'aller-retour sur tel ou tel document
tel ou tel capacité de versement et
cetera mais vraiment on a une réactivité
forte qui s mis en place une
priorisation très forte en réalité hein
sur ces situations et un premier retour
assez favorable la façon dont ça se se
passe c'est encore un peu tôt hein moins
de de mois de de mois de recul mais un
bon voilà une bonne appréciation avec
quelques éléments de vigilance et de
travail pour la suite que je partage
avec vous on a des situations qui
peuvent être assez différentes en terme
d'urgence puisque la loi permet de
remonter enfin d'avoir des faits un an
en arrière donc évidemment dans les
chiffres que je vais repartager je sais
pas si on peut retrouver les derniers
chiffres si vous les
avez 8000 bénéficiaires 12000 demandes
c'est ça
8000 ou 800 € 850 € de M moyen à peu
près quasiment enfin quasiment
exclusivement des aides directes vous
savez que vous avez une modalité aide ou
prês les prêts sont très
minoritaire évidemment 70 près c'est ça
est vraiment à l'émergence du dispositif
euh et donc voilà vraiment un intérêt
fort pour la partie direct mais c'est
c'est
normal donc dans cet effet là dans dans
ces chiffres là il y a l'effet on remte
un an en arrière donc évidemment il y a
des gens qui des bénéficiaires et c'est
fait pour ça tant mieux qui sont venus
mais qui don les pour les fait étent
parfois relativement ancien il dont
situation d'urgence qui peuvent être
variable donc c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'il faudra apprécier dans la durée et
dans le flux normal entre guillemets
j'allais
dire là on a des on a des déjà une
première baisse des sollicitations
hebdomadaires mais ce qui est normal
puisque il y avait cet effet initial
disons mais on est déjà on est quand
même sur des volum son plus importantes
que celle qui avait été anticipé et
estimé mais ça encore une fois ça répond
à besoin sur un point de vigilance sur
la relation avec
les notamment les forces de l'ordre
puisque vous savez que c'est
principalement un dépôt de plainte qui
qui peut être à l'origine de cette de
ces fait ce qui la pratique montre aussi
le parfois l'hétérogénéité du format des
plaintes et parfois un peu la difficulté
pour les gestionnaires de remonter sur
l'analyse de fait qui sont pas forcément
identifiés en tant que tel comme
violence conjugale c'estàd qu'il faut
parfois lire des plaintes assez longues
et malheureusement assez sordide he sur
certains détails et cetera qui de notre
point de vue sont pas nécessaires à nous
gestionner don c'est pas le métier par
ailleurs et qui peuvent être un peu
d'ailleurs pesantesin comme situation
exposition à des situations
individuelles assez lourde et là où on
voit que certains commissariats ont
développé des attestations enité de
dépôt de plainte pour violence conjugale
euh dans d'autres cadres c'était pas
fait pour l'aide d'urgence mais qui nous
paraissent nous assez intéressant parce
que du coup ça nous simplifierait
beaucoup déjà la charge de gestion parce
qu' encore une fois réagir très vite sur
ces situation c'est c'est nécessaire
mais c'est parfois un peu dur dans la
charge et puis ça nous neutraliserait un
tout petit peu les aspects émotionnels
entre guillemets qui s'attachent à des
situations en plus très personnel qu'on
a pas besoin de connaître en
l'occurrence donc c'est un travail qu'on
souhaite mener avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur sur sur ces sujets pour
simp'implifier mais on a quand même des
forces de l'ordre qui sont voilà
présentes et actives et qui outilent ces
sujets mais parfois la qualification
elle-même est pas si évidante à trouver
dans la description de fait qui concerne
de personnes qu'on connaît pas forcément
et dont on sait pas forcément qu'elles
sont en couple hein euh et donc il faut
là aussi améliorer peut-être un peu la
façon d'identifier les choses euh mais
ça fait partie des choses intéressantes
qu'on qu'on commence à faire remonter
sur ce dispositif dont l'utilité est
éprouvée euh on a aussi une hétérogénité
sur la dimension accompagnement social
puisque vous savez on permet aux femmes
concernées de demander un accompagnement
social à cette occasion euh voilà est ce
qui est plutôt renvoie au conseils
départementaux qui se saisissent aussi
progressivement de ce dispositif nouveau
encore une fois donc franchement je leur
jette pas la la pierre c'est vraiment
euh très émergent mais mais quelque part
ça nous donne un socle et un motif de
voilà coordination et des acteurs locaux
sur ces sujet qui qui est intéressant et
qui sera utile quoi qu'il en soit donc
voilà vous savez qu'on expériment par
ailleurs dans 5 départements le pack
nouveau départ euh et dans qure des cinq
départements c'est les cas la CAF qui
est placé en position de coordination
sur sur ce sujet donc tout ça fait sens
aussi autour de la thématique des
violences conjugales donc je vous disais
qu'elle nous était pas totalement uré
parce que on a des situations qui
viennent via le parcours séparation il y
a des gens qui expriment des choses à ce
moment-là mais là c'est plus
spécifiquement dédié sur ce sujet et
donc c'est un axe pour lequel on est
nous nous-même intéressés mais pas pour
dire on fait à la place des autres pour
dire on fait avec les autres et on a un
rôle dans le système et le fait qu'il a
une dimension financière sur cette aide
B évidemment désigne un peu plus la CAF
que d'autres que d'autres acteurs voilà
ce que je peux vous dire dans le cadre
madame la Présidente et bien écoutez
merci beaucououp merci aussi d'avoir
répondu euh un peu hors sujet mais
c'était
important c'est non c'est pas totalement
hors sujet en
plus dans le
sujet et donc bah voilà merci d'être
venu répondre à à toutes nos questions
et nous allons ensuite poursuivre nos
travaux notre rapport
sortira normalement nous devrions le
présenter pour le 29 février flash oui
flash mission
Flash